When we draw on a computer
all we're really doing
is assembling an array of colors.
If you've ever looked at your computer
monitor under a magnifying glass
you've probably noticed that each pixel
is actually three vertical rectangles.
One red, one green and one blue.
And yet, when you take away the
magnifying glass the pixel can look like
any color at all.
Pretty weird right?
This works because the human eye isn't
as good as distinguishing colors as you
might think.
Our eyes can't actually tell the exact
energy of an incoming photon.
So here's our eyeball and here's
the cornea and here's the retina and
here's the optic nerve.
Now the actual sensors in the eye
are three types of cone cells.
And each of these type of
cone cells collects photons
of a particular range of wavelengths.
If a photon falls in the range of the l,
or
long wavelength cone cell,
our brain perceives it as red.
If the wavelength is a little shorter,
and it falls into an m, or
medium cone cell, then it looks green.
And, if the photon has a super-short
wavelength and stimulates the s cone,
it appears blue.
All other colors are just
how our brain interprets
photons that stimulate multiple
types of cone cells at once.
Since red, green, and
blue light each directly stimulate
one of the types of cone cells, this
means we can simulate any other color
by replicating how that color
would simulate the cone cells.
For instance the color yellow is the
results of stimulating both the l and
the m cones, but
it doesn't matter to our brain
exactly what photons were involved.
It could be a yellow laser where every
photon has exactly the same energy.
Or it could be an even combination
of green and red light.
The response of the l and
m cones is the same either way.
So to our brain, it's the same color.
The unintuitive result is that any
visible color can be generated by
a combination of red, green, and blue.
Human color vision is a crazy topic.
And you can check out
the instructor notes to learn more.